شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه ويشرفنا نكون
معكم اعتقد انني سابدا بالحديث عن اكثر
تهديدات الامنيه المقلقه وهي ايران وهذا
يتجلى بعده طرق طبعا هناك المكون النووي
هناك الصواريخ البالستيه والصواريخ كروزا
الموجهه
والطائرات من دون طيار وانتشار كل هذه
التهديدات وايضا من خلال وكلاء ايران في
لبنان وفي اليمن وفي سوريا اذا ممكن نقول
ان هناك سؤال طبيعي ماذا نفعل ازاء ذلك
نحن نركز على شيئا تقويه الشراكات التي
لدينا في هذه المنطقه وهي كبيره وهائله
وايضا نبتكر امور وتقنيات جديده نستخدمها
لتعزيز الامن الملاحي البحري في ضوء هذا
التحدي الذي تتحدث عنه سيدنا ابي الادمرال
كيف تصف الشراكه حاليا مع دول المنطقه مع
الحلفاء التقليديين للولايات المتحده
لدينا
مزيه شراكتان مهمتان وهي القوه البحريه
المشتركه وايضا
البنيه الامن البحري المشترك ساتحدث عنهما
القوه البحريه المشتركه تتالف من 38 دوله
وهي اكبر شراكه بحريه في العالم لدينا قطع
بحريه تجوبو المنطقه وهي قوه سريعه
وديناميكيه وهذه الشراكه تعزز الامن
البحري وفي العامين الماضيه نمت هذه القوه
اضفنا اله قوه مهمات خاصه بخليج عدن وفي
العام الماضي ايضا انضمت الهند الى هذه
واذا هذه القوه الاولى والثانيه هي بنيه
الامن البحري الدولي وتتالف من احد عشر
دوله وايضا حول باب المندب ومضيق هرمز
وكانت هناك ثمانيه بلدان الان اصبحت عدد
بلدان احد عشر كلا الشركتين قويه وحيويه
وتستمر في النمو وسينضم المزيد من الشركاء
ومن خلال هذا النار اننا نعزز الامن
البحري في المنطقه هذه الشركات التي تتحدث
عنها ولا سيما مع الحلفاء التقليديين
للولايات المتحده كما ذكرت هل تتاثر
بالتطورات السياسيه واعني هنا عندما يحصل
التقارب بين ايران من جهه ودول عربيه من
جهه اخرى هل تتاثر هذه الشراكات التي
تتحدث عنها مع الدول العربيه هذه
نحن دائما نترك الدبلوماسيين والسياسيين
ليتحدثوا عن الجوانب السياسيه
والدبلوماسيه لكن انا يمكننا ان نقول
شركاتنا قويه وتستمر في القوه وحاسه تزداد
قوه في المستقبل ساضرب لكم مثلا الان
لدينا اربع
قوى مهمات في القوى البحريه المشتركه
واحده سماء القوه واحد صفر خمسه وتجوب
خليج عمان والشمال الخليج السعوديه كانت
تقود هذه المهمه
وراينا الربع مليار من الدولارات من
الاستثمار فيها وهذا يبين مدى قوه هذه
الشركات ولا ارى اي مؤشر على تغيرها في
المستقبل ذكرت ان التحدي الاكبر في
المنطقه هو الموضوع الايراني ردا على هذا
الكلام يقول مسؤولون ايرانيون ان المشكله
هي في التواجد التواجد الولايات المتحده
في هذه المنطقه
واذكائها لبعض الخلافات
منظوري لهذه القضيه اننا اذا ما القينا
نظر على ما حدث في الاسبوع الماضي راينا
البحريه الايرانيه وبالشكل غير قانوني ومن
خلاله هجوم على السفينه تجاريه ترفع عمل
على من دوليا ثم ادفان في السويت راينا
ذلك على شاشات التلفاز هذه لم تكن حادثه
معزول هذه المره الرابعه عشره في عامين
التي ايران اما احتجزت واستولت او اوقفت
سفينه تجاريه بطريقه غير قانونيه وكما قلت
هذا جزء من نمط وليس حادثا معزولا بعث
القلق قلنا ان هذا يؤثر في الامن البحري
والامن البحري اذا ما تهدد سيهدد تدفق
التجاره الحره في المنطقه وهذا سيمنعني
انا وجميع المشاهدين من الاستمتاع بازدهار
المنطقه هذا ليس سببه الى اي شيء هذا
الامر وهذا التصرفات يجب ان تتوقف نابل
كيف تراقبون تطورات الوضع في السودان ما
الذي يقلقكم مما يحدث هناك
السودان الامر مؤسف وخطير للغايه حقيقه
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده هذه منطقه يقود
العمل فيها تقود العمل فيها وزاره
الخارجيه والبحريه تدعم ذلك وقد طلب الينا
التوفير سفينه حربيه والتي اخذت 600 شخص
واجلتهم الى ميناء في السعوديه وهنا اود
ان اشكر
قائد الاسطول السعودي لدعم الكبير لنا في
المستقبل سوف نستمر بمراقبه الاوضاع الكسب
والامر مقلق لكن ذات الخارجيه تتعامل مع
الموضوع ونحن سعداء بان نقدم لهم المساعده
ولكن ما هي المخاوف لديكم في حال تطور هذا
الوضع الامني كيف يمكن ان ينعكس على الامن
عموما في المنطقه
سوف طبعا انا لن اخذ في التكهنات لان
الحاله ديناميكيه متغيره لكن هدفنا حاليا
ببساطه او ان نراقب وان ننسق ولو احتاجت
وزاره الخارجيه الى اي دعم جديد نحن سعداء
لنقدمه لها طيب لو ذهبنا الى شرق اسيا
سيدنا ابي الادمر كيف تراقبون ايضا الوضع
هناك نسيم على خلفيه التوتر الحاصل
والمتصاعد بين الصين وتايوان ما هو دوركم
انتم في كل ما يحدث
انا اميل الى ان ننظر الى هذه القضيه من
منظور قوه بحريه الى قوه بحريه وتقوم به
الصين ومن خلال التركيز على ما نقوم به من
خلال الشراكات التي اشرت اليها
واهتمام بما نقوم به من بين الخمسه عشر
دوله لديها حدود بحريه انا اقول بثقه ان
ثلاثه عشر منها تنظر الى الولايات المتحده
على اساس ان شريك امني بالتطوع واختيار
منهم البعض الدولتان الباقيه قد تنظران
الى ايران والى الصين
الباقون ينظرون الي هناك شركاء ولا يفعلون
ذلك من خلال الكلمات بل من خلال الافعال
وبشكل عملي اقول في العامل الماضي اجرينا
تمرينا في المنطقه مع شركائنا الصين اجر
التمنينين فقط هذا العام 25 الصين اثروا
التمريرا واحدا نحن على مستويين مختلفين
تماما حاول لك كيفيه الانخراط في هذه
المنطقه وانا اركز على الابقاء على قوه
شراكاتنا والمضي قدما الى الامام الادمن
التوتر الحاصل في شرق اسيا والمخاوف
السياسيه لدى السياسيين في الولايات
المتحده من امكانيه ان يتطور الامر هل اثر
على تواجدكم في منطقه الشرق الاوسط هل
اصبح التركيز
لامن البحار
لان البحار منصبا اكثر على ما يحدث في شرق
اسيا
اعتقد اذا ما عدنا الى الصرف الماضي
وباعلان رئيسنا القوي الذي اعلنه وعززه
وزير الدفاع عننا بالنسبه لما يخصني باننا
كبحريه مهتمون تماما ونركز على هذه
المنطقه هذا ما قاله الرئيس واكد وزير
الدفاع وهذا ما نقوم به واضافه الى
التمرينات التي تحدثت عنها وقبل عامين
اجرينا ثلاثه وثلاثين في العام الذي تلا
اقمنا 77 تمرين هذا ضعف العدد ويتوقع ان
نفعل حتى المزيد هذا العام حتى الماضي
القريب كان لدينا اكثر من 42 بلدا سبعين
الفرد موجود وهذا التزام كبير انتج
المنطقه واقول بثقه انما ملتزمون وهذا
الالتزام يتجلى بعمارنا وانا متفائل
باستمرار هذا الالتزام ما دلاله زياده عدد
هذه المناورات كما ذكرت يعني قلت ان هناك
زياده كبيره ومعشركاء اكثر ما دلالات
القيام بكل هذه الاعمال
هذا يتسلى بعده الطرق اولا من حيث العدد
والارقام هذا يتيح لنا العمل بشكل اكثر
سيوله وسهوله وان نتحرك بسرعه اكبر
وبطريقه مباشره وذات مغزى وان نتحرك ايضا
بكفاءه اكثر حفاظا على الامن البحري اشكرك
نائب الادمر
قائد القوات البحريه بالقياده الوسطى
الامريكيه والاسطول الخامس على هذه
المقابله معنا شكرا جزيلا لك